against bogdanovic fakes the spin the
fade and he sticks it
just brilliant
donovan mitchell just one point in the
second half trying to force the switch
so donovan is against luca
here he comes to the cup lays it up and
in
they need a stop right here
doncic against gobert both teams are out
of fouls
doncic sizes them up there's a three he
buries it
[Applause]
and i told you sparrow that matchup down
the stretch as luca lets the crowd know
that he's back and he's feeling good and
he is the closer for the mavs
luca duncan
mavericks route of fouls conley
kicks out mitchell coming baseline left
it short gets it back contact and he
puts it down
donovan mitchell telling these fans to
make as much noise as they can
you see powell's free-throw numbers
78 on the season
15 seconds
here comes mitchell gobert
utah takes the lead
and it's fitting
give the ball to the big fella duncan
trying to find a man he's got did
whitney
well short
and utah survives
and they tie the series